[Music]
congratulations newsroom this is a big
show it's a big deal and you guys had a
massive premiere like a red-carpet
premiere yeah we had the big premiere
the red carpet and everything yeah how
was it was it for those things fun are
they stressful
well there it's always fun once you're
there but the preparing before it is
like it's just really stressful it's a
you know squeezing into things and the
wrong shoe and like it's like it's a lot
of people looking at you and going mmm
can you suck anymore and can in Oh your
hair looks weird like that and it's this
is everything I get before I go to this
day but but and especially the does your
hair look weird I'm curious about
something did you parents get to go
because I would think this would be a
time where in a red car repair you want
your parents there yeah well I I had my
mom and my I stepped out of my niece and
a big group of my family came I was
actually really nervous because my mom
came to a premiere that I had in New
York and it was my first premiere and
she's so excited this is her daughter
has his movie out so we pull up you know
the car pulls up right by the red carpet
and we jump out and as soon as you jump
out there's just cameras in your face
and so my mom starts posing and then
also you hear one of the photographers
say hey Asian lady out of the way what's
really yeah and I don't know why I
remember this thing I thought that's so
specific it wasn't just like hey out of
the way it was like hey Asian lady case
you weren't sure we're done about you
get other way it is so incredibly rude
yeah and funny
[Laughter]
space was just like she's like watch it
and then she goes but I'm gonna live iam
MUNs mom and then some like one guy was
like oh sorry click click so nervous but
like Oh like it's gonna be bad again and
so this time as soon as we got off I was
prepare like we're gonna take pictures
of my family but you know this we're
taking pictures so we sat there and of
course I'm mom now is just all the time
way to go and now it's like that it's
like our family portrait she has it
framed and up everywhere it's it'll be
on a Christmas it'll be on a thank you
card to you for having me on the show
be a picture of us on the red carpet oh
sure I love that yeah no one ever sends
me a thank-you card
I was here I sent you a thank-you card
oh I remember that
I did it was very nice of you I did get
that yes you're welcome
did you get the flowers I sent ya Oh
something went wrong
those things cost money yeah this is a
true story the first time I was ever on
a red carpet and it was when I was
hosting the late night show I went on a
red carpet I thought I finally arrived
then I went on a red carpet and I'm
walking down and I heard paparazzi going
hey hey hey and yelling at me and I
turned to them I was like yeah and they
said hey you're blocking Jason Priestley
and I had to move out of the way for 902
when I was Jason Horsley but now we're
lovers so it's fine he's got nice hair
Oh beautiful